a lot of the narrative we saw that in
the headlines has been it's going to do
the writing for kids kids are not going
to learn to write but we are showing
that there's ways that the AI doesn't
write for you it writes with you you
know because I want to write a horror
story and it says ooh a Horror Story
House Fine tingling and thrilling let's
dive into the world of eerie shadows and
chilling Mysteries and this is an
activity where the student will write
two sentences and then the AI will write
two sentences and so they collaborate
together on a story the students right
Beatrice was a misunderstood ghost she
wanted to make friends but kept scaring
them by accident and the AI says poor
Beatrice a lonely Spirit yearning for
companionship one day she stumbled upon
an old abandoned mansion etc etc I
encourage all to you know hopefully one
day try this this is surprisingly fun
and we think is this is just the very
tip of the iceberg of where this this
can actually go